hi there steve kaufman
i'm going to talk a bit about language
again guess what
uh i was watching the news uh this
evening on tv
first of all they have the american
democratic convention
and i kind of cringe every time these
politicians drag their families into it
and
and all kinds of uh
you know heart-wrenching stories and
then of course god bless america and all
this good stuff
um but yeah anyway politicians will do
their thing
then there was a program uh where they
talked about golf and they talked about
the decision by the american ladies
professional golf association
to insist that foreign players
have to speak english or there could be
some consequences
and uh so then they interviewed a bunch
of people and the general drift was that
this is uh you know will never stand up
in the court of law this is against
civil rights it's discrimination
the one
foreign player they interviewed who was
swedish said
well of course you should learn english
if you come to north america to play
golf
and of course to me
i mean i just cannot understand the
issue
those golfers are paid by the fans and
by the sponsors this is not the olympic
games this is not the amateur golf of
the world association this is
business
and if people if they don't have
sponsors and if nobody comes out to
watch then there will be no money to pay
the prize money and therefore
that program
is
gonna die
and since those koreans have been very
successful
as golfers
uh and have been very dominant
the winning you know i don't know the
numbers i don't follow it but they're
always in you know a lot of koreans are
in the top
10 or 20 and they're a significant
percentage of the golfers
uh they're playing in front of an
english-speaking audience primarily the
sponsors
uh
apparently they have these events pro-am
where sponsors and important people get
to play pay a lot of money to play with
pros and they want to be able to
communicate
well yeah of course they should learn
english
what's so strange
uh
and trying to make this as some kind of
a
discrimination civil rights issue i i
just i just don't understand it
um
if i go to a country to work
i learn the language
unless i'm lucky enough
to work for an employer if i work for an
english-speaking employer and uh
he has a job for me which only requires
me to interact with other english
speakers well that's fine but that's not
the case with these uh golfers
they have to interact with with their
with their fan base
and i mean i look at people like
sergio as they call him from spain i
mean his english has improved
tremendously
uh lorena ochoa from mexico
i've seen some of the koreans who speak
good english
learn it what's the problem i think it's
quite unacceptable for someone who plays
all of their golf in the u.s and
plays very well to be relying on
interpreters learn the language
what bothered me in this that made two
different references to rosetta stone
rosetta stone isn't going to get you
there with all their pictures and stuff
like that get on to link what i have to
do is i have to approach the american
lpga or some of these golfers and get
them onto link
i mean if you want to learn a language
you learn it language learning is all
about the desire to learn the language
and so
granted
threatening these players may not be
ideal but making it clear that that's
what they expect what's expected of them
that it's not acceptable
to play
to be in show business and not to be
able to communicate with your audience i
don't think that's on
you know unreasonable at all
and my only regret is that i'm not able
to
to let all those nice people know
about how well they could do
um you know if they join link now
granted it wouldn't be a problem if
there were five foreign players who
didn't speak english but
we're now at the stage because of the
tremendous success of the korean golfers
that a significant number
uh of the people winning uh tournaments
now on the lg lpga are korean
so we're no longer talking about one or
two every now and again we're talking
about a significant number and uh i
think that it is quite reasonable
and
any any golfer shouldn't have to be told
that i mean get real
wake up be responsible learn the
language it's not very difficult
that's all i have to say on the subject
and i can't believe the hand-wringing
human rights whatever this is not an esl
class this is not a social service
organization these are people who are
earning a lot of money all of which they
extract
or receive one way or another from the
fans and the sponsors the least thing
they can do is to be responsible and
learn the language and that's my take on